a former vice president Mike Pence has
officially launched his 2024
presidential campaign we're going to
look at two events that he did yesterday
the announcement speech as well as a CNN
Town Hall
I don't know which went worse they both
went very poorly let's start with the
speech in Iowa at which Mike Pence
announced he is indeed running for
president
he is now trying to frame himself as the
Patriot when it comes to the January 6th
Trump riots will the Republican
electorate go for this
I don't know
wow but thanks to the courage of law
enforcement
the violence was quelled
and we reconvened the Congress the very
same day
to complete the work
of the American people under the
Constitution of the United States okay
as I've said many times
on that fateful day
president Trump's words were Reckless
they endangered my family and everyone
at the Capitol
but the American people deserve to know
that on that day president Trump also
demanded
that I choose between him
and the Constitution
and he chose the Constitution
now voters will be faced with the same
choice
I chose the Constitution
and I always will
all right so not exactly riveting stuff
from Mike Pence but he has very little
it's sort of like why are you running
again if people want a pro-trump
trump-affiliated voice they'll go with
Trump and if they want something else
they'll go with someone who wasn't
Trump's VP the idea that anyone is going
to go for Pence is completely and
totally laughable we'll get to the
polling in a moment here is Mike Pence
comparing President Biden and uh Donald
Trump which was an interesting moment
for sure most Americans treat each other
with kindness and respect even when we
disagree
we know how to be good neighbors
that's not too much to ask our leaders
to do the same
but sadly it's clear that neither Joe
Biden or Donald Trump share this belief
I don't think that's true even remotely
in fact if there's a stronger criticism
of Biden is he's treating too
respectfully a republican opposition
that operates exclusively in bad faith
and he shouldn't even bother with them
that's the real criticism of Biden
and neither of them intend to even try
to bring our country together
but I believe it's not just about
civility
to craft real solutions
all right you get it anyway saying
neither Biden or Trump have the respect
that Pence would bring to the race
although it's hard to really believe
that Mike Pence like other Republicans
have tried including Trump taking credit
for the end of Roe v Wade which I don't
know if is a great strategy given that
Roe v Wade was quite popular with the
American people and
maybe most important of all
it was our Administration that appointed
three of the justices that sent Roe
versus Wade to the ash heap of History
where it belongs right
[Applause]
we gave America A New Beginning for life
you know when Donald Trump ran for
president in 2016 he promised to govern
as a conservative
together we did just that
so then why not vote for Trump so anyway
I don't know how popular bragging about
being responsible for the elimination of
Roe v Wade I don't know how good of a
strategy that is it's not clear how
popular that even is among Republican
primary voters never mind Republican
voters overall but this is the approach
Pence is taking and understand that he
has very little else to go on or to run
on he was later interviewed on Fox News
after his big announcement speech and
just almost two minutes of complete and
total nonsense just it's hard to imagine
how this would Inspire even a single
Republican voter today it's Sandra here
most people want to know if they're
considering voting voting for you in the
primary if if they think that you can
win and you've jumped into a field with
your former boss Donald Trump and they
are likely wondering how you plan to run
against Donald Trump not well
well you know we really laid out that
choice today but uh but honestly by the
way who's this we the reason we started
here in Iowa is because uh Karen and I
are going to spend an awful lot of time
in Iowa this fall and in New Hampshire
and in South Carolina you know one of
the things that I've come to realize the
last few years is that I'm I'm I'm I'm
well known but I'm not known well I
think people know me more as a uh as a
as a quiet vice president standing off
the president's shoulder loyally
supporting him all the way until a day
when my oath of the Constitution
required me to do otherwise uh but now
we have an opportunity with all the
great people in this state to travel to
the cities and the farms and and the
byways and the highways and let people
really get to know the penses not just
my years so the question was how are you
going to defeat Trump I'm not hearing an
answer this is vice president but when I
I led the state of Indiana through tax
cuts expanded educational Choice stood
for right to life and of course as you
all know me from years ago when I I was
a leader of house conservatives I I
bucked The Big Spenders in in my own
party imagine thinking that lines like I
bucked The Big Spenders are going to get
you ahead of Donald Trump in a
completely delusional Republican primary
so a quick look at the polls where they
stand right now Mike Pence currently
polling 3.8 percent and you've got to
give him credit he's already ahead of
Vivek ramaswamy he's more than doubling
the polling support of Tim Scott he's
well ahead of Chris Christie polling one
percent at last check but I do not see
any path towards the nomination for
Pence after the break we'll look at
Pence's CNN Town Hall if you thought his
speech lacked energy just wait until you
see this delusional CNN Town Hall after
this short break